the jurogan experience what is it like
to have a movie about one of the worst
experiences of your life
yes thank you for asking it like that
yeah no one ever has it was
it's an honor to do that to to be a part
of that
and um it's funny because people like
hey they made a movie in the books and
it was great i was like man about me
getting my ass whipped
as a fighter and a warrior those are
usually the stories you don't want out
right so i'm in the lost column
i carry a lot of weight 19 promises
i never forget it so i walk around i
always remind myself i can run into
somebody who knows or loved one of them
or one of their family members so i'll
always carry myself a certain way i have
to
that was a deal i made to get me off the
mountain people asked me who my heroes
are everybody who had to come fetch me
out of hell
i was in there pretty deep and um
the way that lined out it's a great
story if you want to hear i mean the
whole process
i would love to hear it it's funny on
the way up here i was like man how's
this interview gonna go and i was
watching dope uh joe dirt last night i
was like let's do it like that you want
to start from beginning
bra tell you some stuff you can't
believe that you said let's start it off
with whiskey
yeah as soon as you said that i'm like
this is gonna go great it is
yeah i only drink whiskey with my
friends and you know the reason we say
that is because the things that come out
when you drink whiskey yeah
so i've been looking forward to this
we've been friends for a while i thought
we should have a good time with it 100
yeah
you know i watched the movie again last
night i watched yesterday just to
prepare myself
and uh i haven't seen it i never watched
it all the way through i know the
director's cut
you know not yeah no yeah so it was um i
can imagine
it was something to back it up to the
book and how that all happened
or you back it up to the military
wherever you want to start
we can go all different directions with
it but i was in i was in hospital so
when i got back
i was in the hospital for a while and
then they
i went back into the teams and started
doing another workup for deployment
and then in between that i was getting
called to the
to the boss's house i've always been
watched over on high ground
that was a blessing because so many of
our guys died
and we had a fallen angel when we have a
fallen angel you all always hear about
it
like normally if seals die or something
it's on the bottom of the ticker or
only the family members here but we had
a fallen angel which means we have an
aircraft going down
and um i didn't know about it actually
when i when the mission started because
everyone who knew about our operation
was on the helicopter
that's why i was out there for so long
and um i remember i was in
i just got out of hospital i was doing
physical therapy at the team and they
called me up
and they said hey we're going to d we're
going to declassify part of this
operation and we're going to put it out
into a book
and i was like okay i didn't know what
that meant
well then they pulled me back up to the
to the
to the headsheds where the we had this
big meeting and they brought they
assigned to me
the i mean i was privileged enough to
have
the best lawyers the best writers like i
interviewed with everybody
until i found a fit like i got to travel
around like when patrick and i met he
came out to the house
my mother fell in love with him so
that's how he we knew he was gonna
and i had to live with him so i would
actually wake up on
sunday or monday morning and go into
work do a work up fixing to deploy
and then on fridays i'd have to fly to
cape cod and i would sit with patrick
and tell him the story and then sunday
night i'd fly back patrick is the guy
you wrote patrick robinson yeah he's the
guy you wrote he was yeah
because my name wasn't in the book it
wasn't supposed to be anything like that
i was still operational
and then i deployed back to iraq in 0607
i ripped jocko out
i know you met him love jocko great guy
and he loves you
man he was he was my bo one of my bosses
he got so excited when he when he heard
you were coming on he texted me and we
went back and forth
hey something i call him he's just what
you see is what you get
he's ever noticed his face looks like it
could perfectly fit in a spartan helmet
yes oh yeah like he's always i mean he's
when it comes to leadership break
glass that's in case of war we have
those guys yes
they're real i know you've met some of
them yeah we need those guys they exist
they're terrifying they i'm so happy
they're real yeah they're real
yeah and jocko is my he's
he's the archetype yeah yeah he was
there's a reason why he's over chris
and michael and mark have you noticed in
the seal teams all of our medal of honor
guys named michael
you ever noticed that no yeah yeah those
are called mark angels
they always get the medal of honor you
get a mark and michael running together
and seal team something bad
it's going to go down so you always joke
about that
but when the book came out i was in iraq
i remember the lawyers and everybody
would they would write me
emails and like please don't die and i
was like well i'm trying not to thanks
jesus christ so i got
hurt in iraq again and when i got back
they
positioned me out of the seal teams and
then
they kind of rewrote that part put my
name in it my job was to go around
and tell you about your boys and what
they did and how hard they fought and
they died
and that was the greatest job it was the
hardest job i ever had to do
because i remember when they pulled me
offline as an operator
and the hammer was sitting there telling
me like son you're going to do more for
the seal teams than you ever did in
combat
and that was i thought that was kind of
an insult i was like wait what do you
mean
right i was like do i need to work out
harder do i need to
he's like no this is what you need to do
so i did that
and i traveled around and i told you
guys and then the movie hollywood came
calling
so i got stationed to live there they
actually sat me down and
introduced me to all the directors and
we had to find the fit and then once
pete and i
linked up for the first time rest is
kind of
i mean peter bird yeah peterburg god
damn he nailed it man i know you haven't
seen it because you've seen the
director's cut
yeah yeah but uh he he [ __ ] nailed it
that guy's a hell of a director
he you know it just there was no
[ __ ] in that movie you know there's
a certain amount of [ __ ]
and i don't know if there's any [ __ ]
in terms of like the reality
of the experience versus the the film
version of it but
there was no uh no gloss
to that film so the way we
i'll talk about when i met pete for the
first time so i got pulled up to la
to interview all of my i was traveling
around
um just getting to meet all of everybody
oliver stone i sat down in front of him
i mean they went through me through the
guy i had had lunch
yeah i was it was pretty cool i remember
meeting him because i wanted to
he was a veteran right yeah and um i
love that guy
the lawyer that i got assigned to he was
great alan schwartz is his name
and and for those have you ever seen
spaceballs yes
okay the schwartz in spaceballs yeah
it's named after him so he's mel
brooks's attorney
this this is this is real that's crazy
this is crazy
that's one of the coolest things why i
got to meet him and i was like wait a
minute you're the schwartz he's like yo
so i i got like a sign to him and then
my literary agent was this guy named ed
victor he's since passed but he was
great because he was a british guy tall
skinny and he would wear the sweaters
with tied around his neck and the
white and black wingtips dressed to the
nines
had that that awesome accent and he
would tell me he's like marcus darling
i'm the seal in this world just
in this environment just let me take
care of this what are you saying how
dare he yeah
and i just kind of like roger that
because if you're the resident expert or
something i'll always
drop in right beside you so i was
traveling around
and i'd been in la for a couple days and
i was supposed to get back to the base
and they were like wait there's one more
guy wants to meet you his name is peter
berg and
i didn't register in my head i couldn't
put the name to he's been around forever
he's like he's down on the set uh
filming a movie called hancock or will
smith
and i was supposed to get on my plane
but we went late and missed my flights
like just go down there and see him i
was like all right
so we dropped down there and he's he's
sitting in his chair and then
uh there's a train scene so there's this
huge train
and will standing i got to meet him it
was pretty cool and pete walks up
peterburg he's like hey let's take a
walk i like all right
and we sat down on this park bench
overlooking the water he's like this is
what i think of this this is what i want
to do
and he kind of shot me straight he's
like before i say anything else i want
to show you a movie that i just filmed
and i want you to watch it so i got to
go to the theater and watch this movie
and then the next day
it was his attention to detail he like
focused on the stuff that you would
normally miss
which makes it kind of realistic i was
like okay cheers
i was like no this if you screw this up
if you do anything to dishonor any of my
friends i'll kill you
he didn't know what to do about that
and i mean look on his face because i
shook his hand
and i had his head and i was like okay
here's the deal it's yours
if you want it if you screw it up i'll
have to
you know no no yeah nothing personal for
real and um
right when that happened i mean he took
it we we made him go to all of our tree
he got
the door was open for him because it was
an assignment most of everything else
the books and the movies and everything
they were shut down except for this one
so when the navy's got your back and you
know
the seal teams man that's how that works
so we sent him overseas
he had to go live with i mean that guy
went through some stuff he came back
early and didn't tell me about it
because some of the stuff he saw
and i was like hey it's real right it's
real and he's like that's all i needed
to see
to change how i feel i was like okay
well let's do this man
and then it started oh so he went
overseas and experienced what did he
experience he they they embedded him
with a seal platoon
oh jeez he got to see them guys and how
they
it's a really cool story i'll let him
tell it
because of what he got to see and what
he got to do and some of the guys called
me from the deployment they were like
hey we put pete through the ringer
i was like good because of what he was
stepping into
and um i mean to this day we're still
best buddies i talked to his son
yesterday okay he kind of comes over and
we do
like he teaches my kids some things and
i teach his kids some things and it's
just uh
everywhere i i go i was always taught to
make a friend over money right
because those are the that's the best
cash you can have as a friend and um
getting to live with him and experience
that hollywood lifestyle was
was amazing i remember showing up at his
house the first day
i was like man why does this place look
so familiar he's like oj's house is
right he lives in brentwood
he's like oj's house is right there i
was like oh yeah okay
and then it just got crazy from there
first time he took me out
i mean those these are great stories
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience